d'ici la fin du 21e siècle selon deux
géophysiciens norvégien si la fonte des
glaces ne ralentit pas l'article
disparaîtra c'est donc une nouvelle
prévision qui s'appuie évidemment sur le
réchauffement de la planète explications
et kronwall devenant et marie pierre
cassignard l'article
cette mère sur laquelle les ours blancs
peuvent marcher mais jusqu'à quand car
d'ici la fin de ce siècle les 14
millions de kilomètres carrés de cette
banquise soit 28 fois la france auront
totalement disparu cette prédiction
ce sont des scientifiques norvégiens ils
avancent d'après leurs études depuis 30
ans l'épaisseur de la calotte glaciaire
a fondu de près de la moitié est le
phénomène serait en train de s'accélérer
un scénario catastrophe que de nombreux
scientifiques internationaux redoute
même si pour l'échéance pourrait être
plus lointaines
si le réchauffement climatique continue
lié à l'action de l'homme ce qui est
fort probable eh bien nous irons vers
une disparition des glaces de l'arctique
probablement à échéance plus lointaine
mais les mêmes les conséquences seront
tout aussi importante simplement elles
le seront pour les autres ça rien de six
enfants plutôt que nos petits enfants de
façon tout à fait naturelle
la banquise fond de près de 20% entre
l'hiver et l'été pour se reconstituer
l'année suivante
mais un nouveau phénomène apparaît
depuis quelques années les fentes
estival serait plus marqué l'explication
la plus avancée
le réchauffement de la planète due à
l'activité humaine
un processus menant à une rupture de
l'équilibré climatique
ce qu'on appelle rupture c'est
effectivement des pros des processus qui
peuvent avoir une durée de
de quelques centaines voire quelques
milliers d'années consiste à modifier
par exemple durablement les courants
océaniques des éléments du système
climatique qui ont une mémoire lente et
qui vont prendre beaucoup de temps avant
de retrouver un régime non perturbées
seule certitude la faune polaire et
l'ours en particulier seront privés
d'une grande partie de leurs sanctuaires
d'ici une centaine d'années